[Musique]
je m les gains
joli comment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais la ferme chez toi même
pas hanter a fait rentrer chez toi gras
durs assez gras dur c'est un poteau et
regardez regardez regardez ces faits là
c'est la danse de la joie aux personnes
chinois n'ont pas été bottées bush
attention ça monte ça rigole attentes de
la suisse écrit concentrer sur leurs
vidéos montval j'adore tes boucles
d'oreilles rate à vue ou par mail sont
calmes mais est-ce que c'était même
créatrice est ce que ce sera la même que
ce collier je crois bien d'habitude
j'aime pas les serpents ah ouais mais là
je mets la main mais cela ne fait même
pas les frichards dont celui là j'aime
beaucoup moi je nie avec la prochaine ça
va
[Musique]
et merde là
[Rires]
[Musique]